comment se passent vos vacances ça
m'intéresse pas je suis pas encore en
vacances dont le foot et l'aisne
écoutez j'ai un intéressement sarr lien
avec la vidéo j'ai eu un intéressement
je dirais même une sorte de fascination
bizarre pour les gens qui arrivent à
vivre normalement
très bien alors qu'ils ont une épée de
damoclès de fou au dessus de la tête une
épée damoclès est à dire des gens qui
ont fait un truc pas du tout légal qui
risque tôt ou tard de se faire retrouver
et d'aller en prison mais qui s'en bat
les couilles et qui vivent leur
meilleure vie d'ici là je trouve ça
dingue ça va pas vous étonnez moi je
suis un stressé de la vie sur sa sur la
légalité par exemple les rares fois où
j'ai fait mes courses et où j'ai oublié
de mettre un truc sur le tapis et que
donc je n'ai pas payé puisqu'il est
resté dans le caddie quand je m'en suis
aperçu une fois rentré chez moi j'étais
pas bien je veux garder à travers l'oeil
de ma porte en me disant tôt ou tard le
fbi à eelv à toquer chez moi l'actrice
mais vraiment je suis resté sept fous
sur sa à tel point que je fais jamais de
cauchemar mais quand j'en fais c'est
toujours la même chose je vais en prison
pour un truc que je n'ai pas fait sauf
que personne ne me croit mais je n'ai
pas fait elle est pro des rêves la dite
moi c'est quoi l'explication je suis
rennais intéressant ou alors ils ont dit
bien trop sur moi j'aurais jamais dû
vous dire ça
les documentaires netflix là sur les
meurtriers je les ai tous eus mais ça me
fait un peu bad et les meurtriers moi
j'ai vraiment j'adore découvrir des gars
qui ont consacré leur temps et leur
énergie à mettre en place des arnaques
hockey des escrocs dans les arnaqueurs
très connu il ya franck à bagard à
bagdad
ah bon les noms se sera jamais ça dans
les vidéos qui est le gars qui a inspiré
le film attrape-moi si tu peux
avec dicaprio c'est énorme bg dans un
autre registre et à christophe
rocancourt un mythomane qui a réussi à
infiltrer des cercles hyper fermé et jet
set aux us qui est devenu mégapot avec
des stars en se faisant passer un coup
pour un ancien champion de boxe un coût
pour un pilote de formule 1 un coût pour
un producteur de films et bref à
l'arrivée il a réussi à voler de
l'argent à certaines stars et a même
vidé le compte en banque de certains
mais celui qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui est son histoire n est pas
si connue j'en avais jamais entendu
parler j'ai sonné un peu autour de moi
il ya plein de gens qui n'avaient jamais
entendu parler tout ce qu'on la culture
vous en avez entendu parler donc partez
maintenant laissez-nous les gens sans
culture à vannes migraine je le dis mal
mais il est mort il va rien faire c'est
un peintre qui a réussi à faire des faux
tableaux et à les vendre et qui s'est
fait au total 30 millions de dollars
son histoire elle est folle que soit sa
jeunesse qu'est ce qui l'a poussé à
faire ça etc
c'est en fait elle est folle elle est
touchante c'est juste un mec qui a été
blessé et comme c'est un énorme raz jeu
il va consacrer une partie anormal de
son temps à préparer sa vengeance
c'est tout bref l'histoire de ce gamin
vraiment intrigué en plus comme je
connais rien à la peinture j'ai été
ébahi en découvrant un peu des trucs de
ce milieu là donc supporter eu je vous
raconte l'histoire de san mamés grain et
attention disclaimer il se peut que je
donne quelques informations qu'ils
soient incorrectes normalement c'est
assez solide ya peut-être genre deux
trois trucs qui seront pas exact
maintenant normalement c'est solide
alors notre chère à mener en 1889 aux
pays bas hans un enfant sensible il est
vu comme fragile par son entourage et il
est pas scolaire il a de très mauvaises
notes à l'école
et pourtant il ya pas des jeux vidéo à
l'époque lui il a pas d'excusé dans son
temps libre à nice découvre une passion
pour le dessin
en gros il a clairement l'âme d'un
artiste mais son père cet immense trou
du cul trouve que les artistes sont des
dégénérés qu'ils n'ont pas d'avenir et
il s'oppose fermement à cette passion
que am développe on veut tous un père
comme celui de anne après le lycée anne
en toute logique il veut faire une école
d'art mais son père l'inscrit de force à
l'école polytechnique de delft mais il
continue sur son temps libre à
s'exprimer via le dessin et la peinture
et va même gagné un prix grâce à une
peinture de l'église saint laurent de
rotterdam
du coup il décide de quitter l'école
polytechnique pour consacrer tout son
temps à sa passion
à 9,1 au bout de ses idées et il intègre
les beaux-arts de delft le temps passe
et anne devient un artiste qui a une
technique très très bonne il est
vraiment techniquement bon je viens dire
deux fois la même chose et vous avez
rien cram et se construit une bonne
réputation de portraitiste dans l'art
moderne
à tel point qu'ils arrivent à vivre de
son art correctement mais c'est ça qui
est drôle est cannes c'est qui va pas se
contenter lui ce qu'il veut c'est le
salut des critiques d'art sauf que les
critiques d'art il les laisse totalement
indifférent
mais il continue de faire
essentiellement des portraits pendant un
moment parce que c'est ça qui lui fait
gagner sa croûte mais après un moment il
se lasse il en a marre et décide de
changer de style de peinture est inspiré
du style de peinture de l'âge d'or
néerlandais ça correspond au xviie
siècle à savoir un siècle où les
pays-bas il rayonnait de malades
culturellement et économiquement parlant
en gros s'est plainte une leur culture
elle était vue comme trop stylé par
plein de gens et à cette époque là il y
avait des peintres de ouf
yahvé rembrandt y avait franck salt je
connais pas de culture est élu je le
connais joas vermeer
anne se met donc à faire des tableaux en
adoptant le style des peintres de
l'époque et c'est là que les critiques
d'art vont s'intéresser à ham et le de
greg c'est bon ils vont lutter gling ils
vont tellement le déglingué qui vont
jusqu'à dire des trucs comme ce gars là
ils pas des imitations fatigué de vraies
oeuvres
en gros ça veut dire mec tu fais comme
les gens il ya 300 ans mais on eu la
chienne et c'est là l'élément
déclencheur de la suite ils se mettent à
haïr les critiques d'art mais il va pas
juste avoir le som est noyé dans sa
haine et se morfond derrière fair and il
a un plan qui est très culottée
il veut du pe humilié les critiques
d'art en peignant un faux tableaux de
vermeer et que les critiques d'art le
certifie authentique ce après quoi am
révélera la supercherie et prouvera au
monde entier que les critiques d'art ne
sont pas crédibles et ne mérite pas la
sainte parole qu'on leur a donné
alors pour faire un faux tableaux déjà
il faut être extrêmement bon en peinture
puisqu'il faut créer une oeuvre vous et
moi si on veut faire un faux tableaux on
va juste se dire combien de temps il me
faut pour être capable de peindre ce à
l'identique un siècle à lui
techniquement il est hyper vont donc
c'est pas ça qui l'inquiète le plus sain
tout de suite la question qui se pose
c'est la question de n'importe quel
faussaires c'est comment je fais pour
peindre maintenant un tableau et qu'il
est tout de suite
l'apparence d'un tableau qui lui a été
pas il ya 300 ans par exemple pour pain
ne va pas aller acheter des toiles il va
acheter des tableaux sans valeur du
xviie siècle desquels il va enlever la
peinture à la pierre ponce
de cette manière il peut pas sur une
toile qui est parfaitement identique à
celle des artistes
de l'époque le challenge c'est que la
peinture qu'utilise and soit très fidèle
à la peinture qu'utilisait vermeer bah
ouais en 300 ans entre temps il ya des
nouvelles techniques qui ont été
découvertes pour faire de la peinture du
coup les pigments ils rentrent pas
exactement pareil anne ça il en a
conscience et du coup il va aller
acheter des matériaux qui étaient
utilisés à l'époque pour fabriquer de la
peinture pour le blanc il va utiliser de
la céruse à base de plomb pour le bleu
il va utiliser une pierre rare du lapis
lazuli et pour le rouge il va utiliser
du cinabre en minerais à base de mercure
autre point aussi c'est que dans le
milieu c'était connu que vermeer qui
peignait ses tableaux à l'aide de
pinceaux fait de poils de blé roanne va
du coup fabriquer ses propres pinceau à
l'aide de poils degrés bref vous avez
compris le vrai challenge de hann du
coup c'est de simuler l'usure du temps
sur son tableau et ça c'est plus de
l'ars et de la [ __ ] de chimie sauf que
am
il a fait polytechnique rappelez-vous
première étape par un tableau dans le
style exacte de celui de vermeer ou d'un
autre peintre célèbre de l'âge d'or de
la peinture néerlandaise
ensuite il la met dans un four à son
degré pour durcir la peinture sur la
toile puis il enroule autour d'un bâton
pour créer des craquelures ensuite dans
ces craquelures il va déposer de l'encré
de chine et de la saleté pour simuler
une accumulation poussière après ça le
tableau a exactement la même apparence
qu'un tableau vieux de trois siècles
mais ils passent pas le test de l'alcool
c'est un test où on frotte un coton
imbibé d'alcool à la toile et si la
peinture bave c'est qu'elle est récente
et que donc le tableau est un faux et
c'est là que année c'est un [ __ ] de
génie c'est qu'il a trouvé comment faire
pour que sa toile passe le thème de
l'alcool
il recouvre le tableau d'un vernis à
base de bakélite un polymère synthétique
qui durcit rapidement quand il est chaud
fait ça c'est wikipédia savent aviez
encore plus le tableau et surtout la
peinture ne bavera plus lorsqu on
l'affrontera avec un coton imbibé
d'alcool
bref c'est en 1937 après cinq ans de
travail intensif que anne est plus que
satisfait d'un de ces faux tableaux
les disciples d'emmaüs et il décide
alors de le faire examiner par le plus
grand expert de l'âge d'or néerlandais
abraham bray dieu visuellement ya rien à
dire tout laisse à penser que c'est un
vrai vermeer
que ce soit les pigments utilisés les
traces du temps avec les craquelures la
poussière dans les créatures etc
c'est un pékin mais il reste à passer le
test de l'alcool abraham frotte la toile
avec un coton imbibé d'alcool et la
peinture ne bave pas il affirme que le
tableau est un authentique et il va même
le recommandé aux propriétaires du musée
boymans ce à rotterdam qui va l'acheter
pour 540 mille florin à savoir
l'équivalent actuel de 4 millions de
plus que ce bon pour vous et à ce
moment-là âme qui reste un humain comme
nous se dit mais attends je dévoile la
supercherie et je les humilie où je
brasse un maximum de tune abba branche
transmission très content
il continue de parler de vente des faux
tableaux de vermeer et d'autres peintres
mythique de l'époque qui finissent à
travers plein de musée dans les pays bas
et en allemagne
il empoche un maximum d'argent effectifs
et voitures de sport casino il enchaîne
les conquêtes il devient même accro à la
morphine un peu bad en bref ils tombent
dans tous les excès se fait kiffer
demain wapa pape mais là on arrive dans
les années 1940 qu'est-ce qui se passe
les allemands envahissent les pays bas
et la hongrie mais se dit [ __ ] fait
chier faut les arrêter
pas du tout à nice 10e des nouveaux
clients venaient voir j'ai plein de
tableau vous vendre ce fait les ayant
une excellente réputation yvan une
fausse toile de vermeer jésus et la
femme adultère à l'un des nazis les plus
puissants hermann goering mais il vend
pas ses toiles compte de l'argent il
avant en échange de 137 vraie peinture
peinture que les nazis ont évidemment
saisit donc volé dans plein de musées du
pays
il faut savoir que la valeur cumulée de
toutes les peintures qu'il a eue en
échange de ce tableau la s'élevait à 1,6
millions de florins donc l'équivalent
actuel de 12 millions de dollars ce qui
fait du faux tableaux de vermeer jésus
et la femme adultère l'une des peintures
les plus chers de l'histoire au moment
de la transaction bref vous connaissez
la suite la guerre se termine les
allemands perdent les autorités
récupèrent donc les collections
personnelles de tous les nazis parmi
lesquels se trouvent
jésus est la femme adultère le tableau
est tracé et les autorités remontent
jusqu'à van hanh migraine il est donc
arrêté il est accusé d'avoir collaboré
avec l'ennemi en lui vendant des trésors
nationaux et du coup là c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est que and i les baisers
soit ils révèlent pas la supercherie et
et risque la prison à vie voire la peine
de mort soit y révèle que c'est un
[ __ ] d'escrocs qui a dupé plein de
gens en leur vendant des faux tableaux
de peintres célèbres de l'époque dont je
vous le rappelle des dizaines qui sont
exposés dans des musées et dont personne
ne doute de l'authenticité
ah ben tu l'avais pas prévu ce dilemme à
après deux semaines en prison and décide
de tout avouer
il se dit il a pas tort qui prendra
moins cher s'il est jugé en tant que
faussaires que s'il est jugé en tant que
gars qui a collaboré avec l'ennemi et
écoutez moi bien ce krach de anne va
même lors du procès dira qu'il a fait
acte de résistance en échangeant un faux
tableaux de vermeer
contre 137 vrais tableaux qui sont
classés trésors nationaux et qu'il a
donc sauvé alors évidemment au début
personne ne croit les autorités se
disent qu'il veut juste tenter de
réduire sa peine en faisant croire qu'il
a vendu un faux tableaux et c'est là que
anne va leur dire ok pas de souci
amenez moi un pinceau et une toile anne
va pendant des mois peindre devant des
témoins et créer un faux vermeer jésus
parmi les docteurs le juge s'aperçoit
alors qu'il a bel et bien fait lui-même
le tableau qu'il a vendu à hermann
goering et laan fait les grands titres
il est élevé au rang de héros par le pop
parce qu'il devient du coup non pas
l'homme qui a fait du business avec les
nazis
il devient l'homme qui a escroqué les
nazis du coup il sait condamné non pas
pour collaboration avec l'ennemi mais
pour faussaires et il se mange la peine
minimum à savoir un an d'emprisonnement
combien tu empochés annan en a quand des
gens bon tout ça va bon la fin de
l'histoire nuls quelques semaines après
le procès il meurt à merde tu avais fait
le plus dur et du cou ironie totale du
sort comme ces oeuvres ont pris de la
valeur
c'est vrai en oeuvre un palais fausse
celle qu'il a signée de son nom il y a
des faux tableaux de anne van meegeren
qui sont apparus sur le marché
des gens se sont fait de l'argent en
faisant la même chose que lui à savoir
défaut sauf sauf qu'ils ont fait défaut
aux offres de lui-même quelle
reconnaissance pour lui bref voilà
c'était l'histoire de anne van migraine
que je trouve incroyable et tout ce game
de l'art de la peinture et où je
connaissais pas du tout donc je trouve
ça hyper intéressant j'adore cette
histoire parce que annie faisait partie
des gens qui ont un vrai talent dans
leur milieu
mais qui se font snobé et prendre de
haut et qui du coup se mettent à
consacrer leur temps n'ont pas à trouver
leur style et à faire des oeuvres mais a
prouvé que les gens qui les ont snobé et
humiliés ont eu tort et qu'il ne valent
rien laisser enfermer dans la vengeance
il a été patient il a été bon et je
trouve ça je trouve ça trop et je trouve
ça fou parce qu'elle la fin de
l'histoire c'est pas qu'il se fait
choper qui finit sa vie en prison c'est
que grâce à son nouveau d'avoir fait un
échange avec un nazi il se prend que un
an de prison
mais ce qui la fait d'illégal là au
final sauver et sax trouve fou c'est que
ça s'est retourné alors t'es pas
l'exemple à suivre
évitons de faire des fausses oeuvres ou
d'arnaqué des gens évidemment bref
j'espère que ça vous a plu
or là c'était une petite histoire que je
trouvais intéressante ça change un peu
des traders on est tous des mois si vous
en voulez d'autres des fois je trouve ça
cool quand j'en vois comme ça qui me
marque j'aime bien raconter et j'espère
que vous aimez
t sinon je ferme la chaîne passer de
très bonnes vacances la prochaine vidéo
serait la dernière de la saison je vous
embrasse très fort bijoux tout le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]